all right let's go to the next category
let's get to the next one hot take of
the year
we're getting right in well this is
getting getting out the big guns already
i have a feeling that i i can't remember
what the nominations are even though we
chose them
yeah i feel that most of these are gone
because god has like god has
just the [ __ ] stupidest takes to eat
he does
like god god is a very god is a very
smart and wise man
and then sometimes god says sometimes
he's like a little too woke you know
yeah
yeah or it's like where did that come
from i i'm just too work when it comes
to like my food opinions apparently
because i i feel like that's yeah that's
that's right that's based as [ __ ] dude
we'll see we'll see we will see let's
get on to the nomination what are the
nominations
oh okay okay so the first one we have is
cross the worst part of the pizza and i
don't eat them let's play
the clip why why does crust on pizza
exist and why does everyone pretend
it's good it tastes good no it doesn't
what a clown i still stick to this
opinion to this day
you know what like i think i think i
remember when i tweeted this out and i
think people who got cancelled
get less hate than when i tweeted this
out like i thought i knew
what a hot take was until i tweeted it
out and i don't think i've had more
replies to a single tweet
than this one but you know it was the
first time i looked at a tweet and i was
like this is why we needed a dislike
button
it's frankly you know i hate to use it
it's just it's a cringe opinion
it's crazy like you know if you want to
you know i have some opinions
where i don't like something but i
recognize that i'm in the wrong story
you know and i think that you should
kind of you know come to terms with it
that you're just wrong
right you know what it's uh it's after
this episode i've gotten like so many
secret messages
from like friends he was just being like
you know what people
actually actually i actually kind of
agree with you you know what i'd like to
cross the resistance i will be i will be
the pizza cross
martyr so that all of us
who are who the crossless gang can exist
i will be the [ __ ] martyr
so that people will know that's a
marvelous get over
yourself it's like you need the crust
right so when you're eating like you get
a little break
from just pizza like as much good as
pizza is you get sick of eating one
noted flavor
exactly except you can dip in the garlic
the wrench whatever you do you know
it's a fantastic oh with ranch it's it's
game over yeah but
okay it's like that's the point right if
you need to have like stuffed crust
or dipping sauce or whatever then that
just means you need to be so
it's a bonus that's like saying like oh
you could make the same argument why put
a pizza on the bread you know it's all
you know
yeah that's like saying like why put
anything on bread when you can just eat
the bread if the bread is such an
inferior ingredient why would you put
ingredients on top of it you know oh
because the crust is just bread i don't
know why not put any viscous breakfast
spreads on my bread
if if i just eat the bread if the bread
is great then why do you need
like you know why do you need to start
saying why everybody stand on base
ingredients like are you trying to get
like another nomination on this one
i've chosen a hill to die on and i'm
dying on this hill okay
and a hill that i'm not proud of is uh
the next one which is
i think steak is [ __ ] mid play the
clip all right
i don't like steak oh my god i think
steak is [ __ ] mid
no man okay okay that that
was an opinion where you know when you
you hear something you have to double
take you're like wait what
yeah that was like the blinking means do
you still stand by that tank
um okay yes in a sense okay
but that but like i say it's me look
okay i don't say
steak is look sounds like backpedaling
because it is
steak is it's i didn't say it was bad
i'll still eat a steak but it's not
hard but it's not it's not my goat no
one has ever been happy about being
called
mid in any capacity if i were to go out
and have like
all right let's have like a slab of meat
for a meal right like chicken pork beef
or whatever like however you cook or
whatever
steak for me is like option number five
or six no
no no steak is like the top tier like if
if we're talking about slab
money is no issue yeah no okay so after
this episode went up i actually went to
a really nice stake place in archibald
yeah where i was like
all right it went up a few places i
think backpedal of the year yeah
next year trash takes yeah over the
years nothing can be a good steak and i
remember when i
first heard this like if my ears could
vomit that's what they would be doing
man i think i think what this just
proved is that i just grew up eating
really mid steak
like i probably didn't have like a
nicely i'm sorry father your steaks were
pretty mean and then actually it's
great because you also have another
shitty opinion oh yeah this one
i think bacon is just not that great
wait was it was this joey this is jerry
i thought it was you both i thought it
was you play the clip play clay play the
clip
bacon is the cheapest part of the pic
right right right and it's [ __ ] and
gammon's like the actual bacon is the
best part of the pig
thank you very much you've been [ __ ]
brainwashed oh it's me
i thought it was jokes no i just i just
agreed with you
you know because i remember i was on the
other side of this argument well no i do
i mean i agree that it's not that great
too far yeah it's not that great it's
[ __ ] great
everyone loves bacon steak is above
bacon for me
it's it's like wait it's like i don't
agree with that i wait as much okay i
agree with that steak is above bacon
mistakes one of the best meats but bacon
is just like no no steak is like in the
middle and bacon is below oh my [ __ ]
god oh my god i still okay i basically
the steak argument i stand by this bacon
argument any other part of the pig is
better
yeah like any other part belly shoulder
that's what i'm like everything else you
know you remember like back in 2012 when
it was like a personality trait to say
that you like bacon
do you remember that when that was the
thing the epic meal time yeah yeah meal
time yeah
oh i like bacon i'm i'm quirky
all right you like a widely available
cheap product okay cool i has
cheeseburger no i has
bacon cheeseburgers i just you know i
think uh i i think it's been
sold to us a little too much by these
these corporations yeah
they've got bacon on everything they
make it seem like it's amazing it's not
it's really cool it is
out of every like part of the pig you
cook bacon people know you're cooking
bacon why because it smells [ __ ]
great it gets the taste buds
the flavor tastes like the smell and
you're just like
that's why they don't make [ __ ] bacon
ramen dude they make it out of the other
part of the pigs
way more flavor way more flavorful
there's so much more richness going on
come on god come on i'm going to argue
with the club all right let's look at
this last one though
uh to me music is just beeps and [ __ ]
but these two of these are mine
yeah two of these are corners i guess i
think i actually am like a caveman when
it comes to music i'm like oh
the beeps in the boobs are very pleasing
music
i think this was the start of the monkey
brain meme wasn't it yeah it was
literally the
wait what is that just how it felt you
were a man
and then this episode you went down well
i mean
i also got a lot of messages people are
like yeah i totally understand what you
mean they're like it's the same for me
i felt like i meant i i met i don't know
brethren no no i i know a few people
with a just like
you know that mean where it's the the
the like the just black outline of the
person the brain caved in yeah that's
that's the crust one
the monkey one is the brain with the
chair like the guy sitting on his head
yeah i mean you know it is what i feel
like this is just like
uh i don't know if it's like genetic
mental whatever it is i i literally
cannot
care about music no no i completely get
this one because so like for me this
isn't so much of a hot take because i
know plenty of people
it's just i've never heard anyone else
describe it as
beeps yeah i i would say i would say out
of all of these this is
not so much a take yeah you know i mean
yeah it's also
because when i used to try to explain
like yeah i don't really listen to the
lyrics like oh what why
and then eventually i just realized just
say you like the [ __ ] beeps
i already think it's a heart take to be
honest but yeah you guys i mean look
let's be real i i probably already know
what the winner of this one is going to
be i mean i think it's a unanimous vote
i'd be very surprised if it's not what i
think it's going to be can we
can we can we appreciate that three of
these came from one episode
and can we appreciate that three of
these are from
no there's three different episodes but
three of them are food opinions
i thought they were all from the same
episode these are all from different
episodes yeah
they're all from different episodes oh
my god i thought all of them are from
the food episode
but we just talk about food that often
we talk about food waste differing
opinions that often yeah these are all
from different episodes
all right let's uh i guess let's get to
the announcement there uh i think this
is
me yeah it'll be the top of your pile
hot take of the year
and the trash taste hot take of the year
goes
to crossed cross cross oh my god
the music is just the beeps and the
boobs yes
what how did that work what the [ __ ]
what an upset
what an absolute
[Music]
i thought this was going to be the
lowest one yeah i thought so yeah can we
get the statistics please
this one with 37.57
point five percent of the votes wait
what was the second place
second place was steak is [ __ ] mid
what
where did the pizza christ come that was
third oh my god there's too many
crustless [ __ ] i was right
[ __ ] is wrong with our viewers why would
you not vote this clown the resistance
was too large gentlemen
i have a dream that one day [ __ ] off one
day
you will not be judged for your
preference of food
but for your love of the scene is this
how britannia felt
like have a dream that one day
the cross this gang and the cross gang
and maybe even the only cross gang
can sit on the same table in peace thank
you very much
rise up the moment the moment i go to a
restaurant there is an
option for crustless i am walking yeah
i'm done i'm like
what do you do what happened i've never
been so [ __ ] proud in my life right
now
i'm so sad this is how britannia felt
when lelouch came through right
how did i get there they're so much
bigger than i thought they were gonna be